in terms of travel measures yes our
opinion is that travel measures should
be implemented in a non-discriminatory
manner that's not to say that we
recommend testing of patient of
passengers coming from the US at this
stage countries need to look at the
evidence base for testing pre-departure
testing when it comes to other measures
since things like mask wearing on
long-haul flights who's recommendation
is that passengers should opt to wear a
mask in high risk settings such as
long-haul flights and this should be a
recommendation issued to who passengers
arriving from anywhere where there's
widespread covid-19 transmission and
pretty much that's across the European
region that's across the Americas and
more or less across the world
recent data from some of these countries
are starting to indicate the growing
presence of the new
xbb dot 1.5 recombinant virus that has
already been spreading rapidly across
the United States
xbb.1.5 variant cases in origin are
being picked up in small but growing
numbers and we are working to assess its
potential impact
from the information available to who
the sarskov-2 virus variants circulating
in China or those that have already been
seen in Europe and elsewhere
we share the current view of the
European Center for Disease Control ecdc
that the ongoing search in China is not
anticipated to significantly impact the
covid-19 epidemiological situation in
the who European region at this time
but we cannot be complacent
while we acknowledge that China has been
sharing virus sequencing information we
need detailed and regular information
especially on local epidemiology and
variants to better assert the evolving
situation
it is not unreasonable for countries to
take precautionary measures to protect
their populations while we are waiting
more detailed information that is shared
via publicly accessible databases
for those countries in origin
introducing precautionary travel
measures at this time
we are calling for such to be rooted in
science
to be proportionate and
non-discriminatory